just before you started with this one
and I want to say that there's gonna be
some French pronunciations not French
speaker I am doing my best though George
Washington Simon Bolivar even pants
Revere the names of the Great North and
South American revolutionaries remain
globally famous centuries on there's one
great new world rebel many have
forgotten he was a nobody he became a
somebody only after fifty years of
obscurity a freed slave who wound up
leading the only successful large-scale
slave revolt in history the general who
made Haiti the second free colony in the
whole of the Americas his name was - saw
L'Ouverture aka the black Napoleon born
into slavery the riveters early life was
an inspiring tale of overcoming a racist
system to live a free man but it was his
later years that were truly remarkable
as he kept on rising until he became
ruler of the society that had enslaved
him an enlightened thinker a prescient
philosopher and a brilliant general
L'Ouverture was also a man who dared to
dream of freedom even if he wouldn't
live to see those dreams fulfilled this
is the story of the greatest black
revolutionary you ever lived
[Music]
imagine history is a vast cave swirling
with shadows and each person's life is a
distant torch some of those lives like
Napoleon's are gigantic pyres burning so
brightly that you can't possibly miss
them
but others most of them are little more
than matchsticks almost invisible it's
into this category the early life of to
saw that overture falls remarkably for a
man who would go on to liberate an
entire nation we know almost nothing
about him we can say for certain that he
was born in the French colony of
Sandeman now known as Haiti and 1741 to
slave parents we can also say that his
original name was too somber Aida after
his plantation but beyond that
everything is myth and shadow the life
of a slave in sand a man was not pretty
90% of the population lived in shackles
while a few tens of thousands of whites
and freed coloreds as they were known
existed in a state of luxury
the average slave life expectancy was
only 21 years those who downed tools
fought back or ran away could expect to
be blinded or mutilated yes to saw was
lucky one of the consistent themes of
the conflicting accounts of his early
years is that he was born onto the
plantation of a relatively enlightened
master the man who owned you saw taught
him french allowed him to gain some
medical knowledge and promoted him to
and job as a horse trainer in 1776 II
even granted to saw his freedom it's at
this point to saw briefly returns to the
historical record he married and had two
kids and remarkably even owned a slave
the zone after this 15 more years passed
in which to saw left not even the
slightest footprints on history by the
time 1791 rolled around he was 50 and
age at which most normal biographies are
starting to wind down by 50 Napoleon had
already conquered half of Europe been
defeated at Waterloo and can send him to
exile by comparison Tucson was a small
time farmer a mere ember in that dark
cave of history that Sala Tucson had
every reason to believe he was going to
die in nothing but obscurity thankfully
for our story though
of change were starting to blow in
Europe in no time at all to saw and
everyone in Sandom ah would be consumed
by the oncoming hurricane
[Music]
in 1789 a group of French radicals
unknowingly lit the fuse on a gigantic
pile of dynamite marked the French
Revolution the ensuing explosion would
shake up human history in most cases the
effects wouldn't be felt until a few
years down the line but sanderman wasn't
most cases it was a radical tinderbox
barely kept in a shack by far away Paris
almost as soon as the French Revolution
sparked the entire country went up in
flames
by mid 1791 everyone else and Ammar was
aware of the storming of the Bastille
and the Declaration of the Rights of Man
this was a problem because the
Declaration was pretty clear that the
rights of men were universal which in
Santa man they pretty clearly were not
though I'd stomped on the coloreds he
dumped on the freed blacks he dumped on
the slaves with the whole system
designed as a pyramids of exploitation
if everyone was suddenly equal Sandman
would cease to exist for whites the
French Revolution represented both a
threat and the chance to split off and
declare a white supremacist Republic for
the coloreds it represented a chance to
finally knock the whites down a peg or
two
that year the two sides were almost
openly plotting revolt in doing so they
failed to realize that a much larger
group had seen in the revolution and
even bigger chance they did out on the
plantations and in the darkness of the
forests black slaves had begun
whispering to one another by the summer
the whispers had turned into an idea
which in turn became a plan finally on
the night of August the 14th 1791 a
group of slaves met outside the capital
of look happens performed a secret
voodoo ceremony there under the stars
they swore by blood to do the
unthinkable
they agreed to revolt if the French
Revolution started small before
snowballing into an unstoppable
avalanche the Haitian Revolution went
straight to the annihilating wall of ice
and fury on August the 21st thousands of
white plantation owners were woken by
gangs of slaves dragging them from their
beds stabbing them shooting them beating
them to death French children were
dismembered their heads displayed on
poles outside of their
homes fires were started entire
plantations burned to the ground
The Horizon returns an apocalyptic read
the bloodshed was nearly worse the freed
slaves in the countryside and the house
slaves in the towns had intended to
coordinate the uprising but the field
slaves jumped the gun and the whites and
coloreds were able to round up and
Massacre the town slaves but it only put
off the inevitable
by late September over 100 thousand
slaves were in revolt in lockup was
flooded with refugees carrying horror
stories of rape and mutilation the
Haitian Revolution it had begun so where
was Tucson in all of this well he was
lying though refusing to even the
uprising or to condemn it something he
was simply waiting to see if the revolt
was going to burn out others think he
was giving his distance in case of white
reprisals
whatever the reason a September turned
into October and the fires grew until
the countryside looked like a vision of
Hell fifty-year-olds Tucson finally made
his choice
first he shipped his wife and children
off to Santa Domingo the Spanish colony
occupying the other half of the islands
today known as the Dominican Republic
then he quietly smuggled his old wide
master and his family onto a boat headed
for the USA at last with no one left to
care for he freed a slave abandoned his
farm and disappeared into the forest it
was the start of what would become a
remarkable career but not straight away
because of his medical knowledge to
swords first posting was less black
Napoleon and more male Florence
Nightingale a doctor for George Adebayor
sells slave army he kept out of the
thick of the fighting as 1791 raged on
and the bodies began to pile high by the
year's end some four thousand whites and
fifteen thousand blacks were dead the
economy was in ruins the plantations
were husks and a third of San Dimas was
in the hands of the rebellious slaves by
the time 1792 dawned though tea saw was
finally beginning to show his promise
given six hundred men to commands he
quickly proved such an effective fighter
that his ranks ballooned to four
thousand although he was still answering
to buy a cell he now effectively had his
own army among their number was
jean-jacques Dessalines right-hand man
while two Saul's army gained fame for
showing clemency to any White's they
captured the seller went in the exact
opposite direction a sadist with an
overwhelming hatred of wives Desa law
would inflict old plantation punishments
on his captives gouging out eyes and
mutilating any French that he
encountered before displaying their body
parts on pikes yes it would be wrong to
call Desa law merely a psychopath
everything he did to his white captives
it seemed done by whites to slaves
countless times before white planters
had buried slaves alive bored them to
death made them eat their own excrement
it said that the sleep of Reason
produces monsters well des Alam was the
perfect monster for a system that had
long ago lost all sense of reason with
decimals help do-seong was able to
capture a huge swath of the country's
north as 1793 began their partnership
had turn to psalms fighters since
perhaps the most effective slave army in
Santa Marta liver a cure which can be
read as opening the way possible
reference to his military victories but
the war on Santa more had reached a kind
of stalemate White's were holed up in
their cities the coloreds were
attempting to establish a separate state
in the south the other slave army
commanders were just as powerful as to
saw what the commander needed was an
outside force that would come and give
the entire war a gigantic shove luckily
that was about to happen 1793 is the
year both Spain and Britain decided to
invade San damar
[Music]
it was the chaos in metropolitan
mainland France that allowed the two
super powers to act with impunity 1793
was the year of the reign of terror in
the anarchy the revolution had unleashed
no one had any time to care about what
was happening in the colonies
Santa Mar had long been prized by other
Caribbean powers and both London and
Madrid wanted to take it but while the
British just straight-up invaded the
Spaniards arrived with a plan their
colonists in Santo Domingo opens
communication channels with the slave
army leaders promising to respect their
freedom if they fought for the Spanish
crown it was a political masterstroke
most of the slave leaders signed up to
fight for Madrid's
including the overture they were tired
of France and saw nothing new under a
British regime accepts a change of
language however there were good reasons
for thinking L'Ouverture wasn't exactly
down with this pledge of allegiance to
Spain as we're about to see come some of
the remaining French troops in Santa Mar
were in a desperate position but their
fortunes they were about to change the
chaos in Paris had briefly calmed down
enough for the new Revolutionary
Government to send out a delegation led
by the portly abolitionist legarre for
the seat salt relax
arriving in Haiti sulfone acts quickly
Divine's that there was only one way to
save the colony from implosion and
conquest and it just so happened to
align perfectly with his own beliefs
while always the 29 1793 he did the
unthinkable he unilaterally freed all
the slaves at first louver tor didn't
believe him
but as 1794 lumbered interview it became
clear that not only did soften acts mean
to keep the slaves free the government
in Paris actually backed him it was at
this point that low voter and made the
decision that would catapult him to
greatness louver tours army had taken
control of the mountains giving them a
natural easily defended base so
L'Ouverture knew that he was in a
position of strength when he announced
that he was defecting from the Spanish
from now on he would be fighting for the
French the decision changed the course
of the war over - Asami marched down
from the mountains and decimated the
Spanish forces and their black allies
generals who'd nominally been the
Superior's only days before found
themselves forced him to retreat into
Santo Domingo as L'Ouverture kept
driving forwards the Spanish eventually
capitulated having just lost a separate
water France in Europe they agreed to
give up Santa Domingo their vanquished
black allies while they were sent into
exile but Bluebird cure he wasn't done
yet pivoting his army around he now
launched his full force against the
coastal cities occupied by the British
although the British would cling on to
their Santa Mar enclaves for a few more
years the game it was up under new
videos onslaught they were beaten down
until the general was able to make peace
on his own terms the deal that Britain
could restart trading with Santa ma on
the sole condition that L'Ouverture
refrained from fomenting slave rebellion
in Jamaica since lo vetere new British
trade would be key to rebuilding the war
shattered economy this was a win-win he
got everything he wanted and the British
got to back out with a shred of that
dignity still intact
as the British slowly packed up and left
the overture turned his attention to the
difficult problem of peace for the
remaining whites and coloreds this would
have been a time of paralyzing fear the
slave armies were notorious for their
massacres and life under a former slave
must have been terrifying prospect they
had not counted on the overtures
greatness rather than reprisals Lovat
Europe pursued a policy of
reconciliation he forgave war crimes
committed by whites he invited the
plantation owners back offering them the
same plantations that owns before in the
chance to make their money back he
instituted a policy of colorblindness
everyone would be equal and no white
would persecute any black just as no
black would take vengeance upon any
white for the slaves he maintained their
freedom they would have to return to
their old plantations and work for two
years but they would receive wages and
corporal punishments would be banned
after their two years were up there'd be
free to go wherever they pleased it's
moments such as these that show white
isola over to you remains a fascinating
figure it was a man who'd just spent
five years fighting a brutal race war
and now he was extending the hand of
friendship to the very people who tried
to kill him northern just a general new
video was
of being a statesman whose pragmatism
could rival Washington's but there was
still a dark side to leave it here and
it went by the name of jean-jacques
daesil in the carnage of the Civil War
the coloreds had succeeded in carving
out a small state in the south under the
command of Andre rego in 1799 lo vetere
sent us alarm down to terminate the
outpost which decimal did with extreme
prejudice the war of knives was brutal
doesn't all slaughtered anyone who could
even conceivably be a supporter of Rigo
leaving a trail of death in its wake
while over 200 was busy consolidating
power in the North by exiling somethin
ax and other French authorities des
along turned the south into such a
wasteland that reconciliation with the
coloreds became impossible bloody as it
was the war of knives did succeed in
reunifying Santa more for the first time
since 1791 the entire country was under
the control of one man and man was low
voter as the clock ticked over and the
19th century began low voter was slowly
rebuilding the economy re-establishing
race relations between blacks coloreds
and whites and making plans to eliminate
slavery and Santo Domingo in short this
extraordinary man was at the peak of his
career it would take the arrival on the
world stage of a man even more
extraordinary than the overture to stop
him unfortunately for the population of
Santa more that man was already waiting
in the wings
[Music]
just as the black Napoleon was
consolidating his control over San damar
in Europe the real Napoleon was doing
the same thing with France 1799 so
Napoleon Bonaparte go from being a
general in the Revolutionary Army to
First Consul of France as it is with
many great men one world stage simply
wasn't big enough for both of them one
of Napoleon's first acts was to declare
the French colonies would be governed by
special rules meaning the Declaration of
the Rights of Man would not apply
since louver to your own has not
actually declared independence from
France instead insisting that he was
ruling on behalf of Paris this was
something of a problem everyone knew
that a slave economy could not be ruled
by a former slave not that things went
immediately south though Lovat you are
publicly praised Napoleon recognizing
him as the new leader of France and he
swore his loyalty to him his actions
seemed to mollify Napoleon the First
Consul confirms low virtue as the
legitimate leader of the colony of Santo
ma but he also issued him with a warning
low voter was not under any
circumstances to invade Santo Domingo so
now can you guess what overture did next
at the time Santo Domingo was a vassal
state technically ruled by France but
still in the hands of Spanish
administrators it also continued to
practice slavery something low voter
couldn't tolerate on his doorstep in
1801 he marched in seize the country and
declared slavery abolished back in
France the melt hits the ventilator
incensed violent virtuous actions the
government demanded something be done
Napoleon himself equivocated he had a
vague plan to invade America and
recognized that san dimas' slave armies
could help make that dream a reality
but his wounded ego eventually got
better of him at the end of 1801 the
first console despatched a military
expedition under the control of Charles
Leclerc to retake Sandom all not long
after he passed the law of May the 20th
bringing slavery back to the colonies it
was the beginning of the ends of both to
Sola overture and French control of
Santa ma on paper Livadia should have
been able to rally popular support in
the face of a French invasion
sadly in reality his new equal society
it's not very popular the economy was
still a fam balls and Lee returned
White's resented the empowered blacks
the coloreds still remember decimals
atrocities and the blacks well they may
have technically been free but they were
still stuck on their plantations of the
three major demographics on Santa ma not
one felt comfortable with the voters
failing state as Leclerc made landfall
first the whites flocked to his side
then the coloreds and then many of the
slaves finally even jean-jacques de
saln turned on his old friends and
threw his lot in with the French and
this well it was the end for over tear
after a few months of token resistance
lever to your contacted Leclerc and
promised to lay down his arms in
exchange for a guarantee that the French
would not reimpose slavery
the clerk agreed and to saw suspended
military operations retiring to his old
farm he was surprised with an invitation
to meet a French general at an
out-of-the-way plantation it was clearly
a trap but L'Ouverture was maybe just
too tired by his sudden fall from power
by that point whatever the reason he
accepted as he arrived at the meeting
spot
he was arrested under the orders of
Napoleon himself and deported to France
do solo over to your man who had freed
the slaves ruled Sante MA for one brief
shining moments would never see his home
again sent to the Jura mountains in
southern France lower-tier spent the
next year being beaten neglected and
left to rot he wrote a bits likely
dreamed a lot of us in the cold mountain
air his health collapsed by this point a
man in his sixties louver to yours body
soon failed him he succumbed to repeated
infections before finally slipping away
on April the 7th 1803 like his white
counterpart words in 20 years the black
Napoleon died alone unloved and in exile
his achievements seemingly forgotten
before he went though overture did have
time to write his thoughts down on sand
Amar's future he felt the genie was out
of the bottle and soon another black
like him would come along to permanently
free the slaves and expel the French he
was more right than in you as he lay
dying there's a law I had switched sides
again the clerk responded by trying to
commit genocide against the slave
population even using ship holds filled
with few
as primitive gas chambers this was a bad
decision the dark force driving the
salon was more than equal to the clerk's
demons and in a genocide or war there
could only be one winner in 1803 Dessel
all systematically exterminated all of
the whites in santa more then women
children soldiers civilians each were
butchered by a roving caravan of death
that offered no mercy only poles Brits
and Americans were spared the former
because many of them had arrived with
Leclerc only to switch sides the latter
to you purely because des along knew
that he needed British and American
trade to rebuild the economy the Clarke
himself didn't live to see this final
French defeat he died of yellow fever in
November of 1802 just after launching
his campaign of genocide On January the
1st 1804 Desa law renamed the nation
Haiti and declared independence from
France the slaves done the impossible
that fought for their freedom and that
one although Haiti would endure
centuries of economic misery natural
disasters and occupation by powers
including the United States it would
never again be ruled by France all of
this happens because of one man - song
level-2 may not have lived to see it but
his nation could never have won its
freedom without him it's thanks to the
black Napoleon that Sante ma didn't
nearly become another British or Spanish
outpost and it's thanks to his
insistence on ending slavery that
Haitians remained free from 1794 onwards
he was a great commander a shrewd
statesman and a man who tirelessly
advocated for racial equality his dream
of creating an equal sound amamiya
failed but it was a noble dream all the
same for that reason if no other to saw
life or cure the slave who became a
leader deserves to be remembered so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a like below and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday and hit that
Bell button because subscribe doesn't
work like it used to on YouTube if you
actually want to get our videos in your
notification feed you do need to hit
that Bell so do that and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]